paul bocuse regarde en l'air il
contemple son plus bel orgue de
mécanique 10 mètres de large 5 mètres de
haut prévu pour remplacer 110 musiciens
au début vers 1900 alors qu'istres
fonctionne à la vapeur
un peu plus tard l'ordre fut enfermé
murray au fond d'une pièce pour que la
guerre ne la bim pas on ne le retrouve à
caen 69 le coeur musical battait à peine
paul bocuse l'a remis sur pied wassim
l'a fasciné c'est quand j'étais jeune
que y arriver à colombo bayahibe la
drogue
la voix vous savez c'était la fête
foraine et un manège de chevaux de bois
les grâces manel fall braya limonaire et
je passais des heures à regarder ses
cartes ont défilé dans cette boîte à
musique
mais face à le fascinait paul bocuse
possède 9 org tous restaurés flambant
neuf mais à l'intérieur des histoires
anciennes se cache le père trois vols
perdent et des enfants 3 vont ils
arrivent vers l'orgue et dit paul paul
qu'est ce que c'est il s'approche
ah oui c'est bien ça il chante quand la
fille de joie
cet homme était dans un bordel
saint-etienne